Rober the Buckeyes sports columnist for
Columbus Post Dispatch joins us thanks
for your patience they're robbing our
nonsense here how is Nick BOCES decision
playing amongst the Ohio State fans well
you know Buckeye Nation Dan so he's
gonna be a little mixed they love him
one day and then when he says he's
departing to go out and spend some time
with Joey his brother and train and
Rehab and leave the team suddenly he's a
traitor and they have no use for him so
I think that's a smaller segment but
it's they're all the same you know they
don't like where college football is
going which is guys maybe sitting out
not playing in bowl games and Christian
McCaffrey kind of started that whole
thing in 2016 with the bowl skip and
last year even though I owe State Denzel
Ward skipped the Cotton Bowl it hasn't
hurt him too much you know I'm great for
the Browns so yeah so that's what kind
of what's going on here that it's all
being lumped together I think this might
be a bit of a one-off here's a guy that
got injured fairly serious injury and
he's just deciding to you know what Go
Go Pro and I can't blame him that's what
college is for right start your career
but I'm trying to understand the
seriousness of the core injury and to
shut it down when was he expected back
first question and was he running any
risk or more of a risk of re-injuring
that that's a great question not he
actually you know this corpuscle injury
is sort of a new term for what we would
call a sports hernia it's essentially
what it is and it can be anything from
pretty simple to pretty extreme I talked
to a doctor yesterday said he assumes
that this is a pretty serious thing but
you know they weren't even going to look
at him till November so it was kind of a
moot point anyhow that that was that was
going to be the reevaluation so could he
come back for you know say if they make
the playoffs yes I don't think he'd be a
hundred percent so when I come back if
you're not going to be really the Joe
the Nick fossa that maybe was in the
Heisman you know discussion
also you know this defense is not
formidable you know I thought that they
were get a bull and you got Perdue
coming up and you know Michigan is now a
legitimate offensive threat unlike maybe
years gone by
so let's handicap this now with Ohio
State with this defense that's maybe a
little more susceptible or vulnerable
how do you see this playing out during
the regular season and to get to the Big
Ten title again
well Purdue is a challenge States has
struggled against really past happy
teams like the Boilermakers and both
have made a difference there's no
question about it he was a game changer
with offensive scheming how they how
they accounted for him he made the
linebackers look better you made the
secondary look better I think they get
past Purdue because
typical high state is everyone talks
about trap game and this is a tough game
and they rise to the occasion and the
week after that they lose yeah it was
Iowa you know so I think Michigan is a
real test I think Michigan is going to
be a real deal and the game which is
kind of dropped off because it really
hasn't been much of a rivalry in terms
of results I think this is a year maybe
it gets back back on track
and it feels like BOCES teammates were
backing him up at least some of the
public comments that I saw big here's
the only thing that he's the team
captain that that probably bothers me
more than maybe it should but it doesn't
feel like it bothered some of the
marquee players on this team who tweeted
out stuff about Nick Bosa like hey he'll
get paid bro yeah a different culture if
this was 20 years ago I think we see
different responses I think these guys
all come to Ohio State now with the NFL
in mind not that they all didn't before
but I think it's you know get yours and
you know I James Franklin Penn State
made an interesting comment yesterday
which was he kind of hopes for the day
when rehab centers when guys can rehab
at the school I think that's a whole
other issue where you know I mean both
it feels like he has to leave Ohio State
to get what he needs to get ready for
the draft what if every college had that
but
that's down the road and I'm not even
sure what I think about that you become
you know just a whole different entity
at that point of rehabing guys for the
NFL but yeah I think the captain things
a little bothersome and I think that's
what people are hooked into to be upset
about but we did hang around practice
for a while and and now he's scooping
off so I think this will pass soon as
Michigan Week comes this will be
forgotten thank you rob we appreciate
your time and thanks for joining us
thank you Dan that's Rob baller the
Buckeyes sports columnist for The
Columbus Post Dispatch for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]